-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Miley Cyrus.
And we mentioned your family.
You have a very loving,
supportive family.
You also might have the world's
best godmother.
-Yeah.
-Dolly Parton.
-I'm pretty lucky.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You guys did a Super Bowl
commercial together.
-Yes.
-You've done album work
together.
-Which, it was amazing because,
you know, she was doing
it for the phones, yet every
time I coordinate and kind of
communicate with Dolly,
it's still through fax.
-You have to --
-So I don't know
what she's talking about.
She's rarely on the phone.
Next time we have to do it for
the fax machine.
-So if you see her in a
commercial talking about
how great phones are, just know
that's some false advertising?
-We do use the phone, but she
does a fax, and then someone
scans the fax, and then they put
it into a text message,
and then that gets sent to me.
-No.
-Yeah.
And it's always signed.
So now I've kind of started
my own version where I go
into the notes, and I've started
to try to make my own letters,
because there's something so
amazing just about a connection.
It's just not casual, you know?
You know that she took the time.
-Yes.
-To get out, I guess
her typewriter?
She also made me a demo one time
where she talks about being
super high-tech, but it was all
through a cassette,
which then she voice memoed onto
a flip phone,
which someone then put on to
the iPhone,
which then got sent to me.
-I like that she recorded it
on a flip phone,
then she Fedexed you
the flip phone?
-Yes. She has a phone.
She just doesn't use it,
I don't think.
I think someone uses it for her
and does the fax machine
through the phone.
-I mean, I should make it
very clear that while
we're joking about this,
nothing would make me happier
than if somebody
knocked on my door and said,
"Fax from Dolly Parton."
-Yeah.
-I'd be like --
-From like, a pink pigeon or
something.
A flamingo probably delivers it.
-It's just, like, a pigeon
knocking on the glass
outside the window.
-Yes.
With long acrylic nails,
big boobs, and a blonde wig.
[ Laughter ]
The Dolly Pigeon.
-"I think that's
Dolly's pigeon." Yeah.
-Yeah.
-You did a cover of one of her
songs last time
you were on "SNL."
Did you tell her beforehand you
were going to do that,
or did she find out?
-Well, that's another
Lorne thing. I didn't know
beforehand I was gonna do that.
-Okay, so what day
does he let you know?
-That was on Saturday afternoon.
-No!
-Saturday, he gave you
a new song?
-Elon had a very long monologue,
and then they needed
to fill however long of time
that song is.
-Oh, gotcha.
-And didn't have the sketch in
between there and,
"Miley, you're doing it."
-Wow.
-So I kind of do -- I don't --
I guess my brand is kind of not
listening to anyone, but I
listen to Lorne Michaels.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-That's a good guy to listen to.
-Okay, gotcha, and then what did
Dolly think?
Did you get good feedback
via fax?
-Yes, I got a fax.
-Oh, good.
-And she loved it, and she loves
when I introduce my fans
to music in a way that's
still me rather than --
Dolly doesn't
want anyone to copy/paste.
She doesn't want anyone to just
sing her songs.
She wants them to infuse
themselves into her music,
because that's what I think has
made Dolly so loved is, again,
the authenticity.
I've taken a poll.
I think Dolly is the most loved
person on the planet, right?
-I think that that's probably
a safe bet.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And again, it's just, she's been
so consistently caring and kind
and herself.
And again, she didn't look like
the standard female
country music artist that was
polite and wearing long dresses.
She had big hair and big boobs
and she's left this big mark
on the entire world that all of
us are just trying to fill her
crystalized shoes, which is
never going to happen.
-She was here once, and I went
backstage and I told her
my son's favorite song is
"Jolene."
And she was like, "Well, let's
Facetime him right now."
-How cool is that?
-So I Facetimed and she sang
"Jolene" to them.
-No way.
-And now the bummer
is they think that I can just
do that.
-And that you can just call
Dolly whenever.
-Because they have a lot of
thoughts, they're like,
"Can we just -- we'd love to
talk to Dolly about this."
[ Laughter ]
-That's awesome.
-I know we were talking about
being back on the road,
touring again.
I have to ask about this --
you were in an airplane
that was struck by lightning.
-Yes. Yes.
-What was that like?
-It was really scary.
I was in my mom's lap, 'cause I
was pretty sure it didn't matter
about the seatbelts,
at this point.
-Okay, gotcha. So when you were
in your mom's lap
because you were already afraid.
-I was crying and I was scared.
And it was really very strange,
because it
was unexpected weather,
and a few things that day --
when I woke up that morning,
I said, something just kind of
felt off and not quite right.
And when we were on the plane,
it was completely unexpected.
And yeah, we got struck by
lightning, which then, we had to
do this emergency landing
and we were in the middle
of South America, and I was
actually on my way to a show,
which by that point,
had been flooded and canceled.
So there was just a lot going on
and everyone's like --
my guys in my band who are just
rock'n'rollers are, like,
"We got to get to the fans!
We got to still play the gig!"
I'm like, "Okay, no, we're in
the middle of, like, the forest
in a broken-down airplane.
There's floods where we're
supposed to be going,
the stage is sinking."
And so Brazil, where I was
playing a couple of days later,
they were awesome.
They let us in a couple of days
early and we were able
to kind of take a few days to
recuperate, just because all of
us were a little traumatized.
-[ Laughs ]
Yeah, that makes sense.
That's very fair.
Well, we're glad you're safe.
We've been very happy to have
you here.
Thanks for everything.
-Thanks for having me.
-And I can't wait --
-Club Fred!
Hey!
Miley Cyrus, everybody!